wait queen of five no no but queen of  five maybe king h4  ah beautiful oh my god that is stunning  that's fantastic  okay oh my god okay g4 also makes a lot  of sense  g4 queen e5 rook 87 checkmate  so this is game over even  anishi's trick didn't work oh my god and  look at aliban he  is you know what what and even a niche  smiling even an eastman these two are  such good friends  and anish knows what's coming up after  this just a lot of twitter trolling  adiban's had a terrible event so far but  playing 1v3 and  winning this game has been the highlight  for him  uh yeah i i don't know what to say  okay that i've just i've just seen  addy's reaction  so he did a little bit of a fist mom  celebration uh right there  yeah that's that's really nice